[Music]
in every civilized community there's an
outcast from a young age the outcast has
trouble fitting in can sometimes feel
invisible thank you and often has
difficulty finding a mate but despite
all the outcasts still searches for a
connection
[Music]
the world of the oh my god what's a peak
we request the honor of your friendship
how you doing welcome to our new frailes
there's something going on here these
pigs mysterious that weird am i right
that part about them I really admire I
don't trust your opinion is not me
doctor yes we have a burn victim here
what do we do now you're asking me you
tried to tell us but we didn't listen
we're gonna get those eggs back come on
we're birds we're descended from
dinosaurs we're not supposed to be nice
oh yeah point made rest in peace by
first
popping up - move your butts it's time
to get angry
she can shoot fireballs out of her butt
[Music]
guards there is a rare bird in these
halls
bring him to me knock in the walls in
the castle come on you guys
[Music]
[Music]
suddenly appear every time you are near
me hey rat how are you oh I'm horrible
we're gonna be working on managing our
anger through movement eagle heron he
cut warrior boundary rabbit this focus
King pigeon and of course downward duck
look sometimes when I get upset I have
been known to blow up excuse me
party foul
[Music]
unbelievable where can network Oh
wherever going we practice this a
hundred times
give it to me we're gonna come in again
[Music]
this new year
when everyone around the world is busy
making resolutions we all know aren't
going to last make a promise you know
you can keep to just be yourself
nice chat why do the Angry Birds movie
wishing you a Happy New Year in theatres
this may in 3d and RealD 3d
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how are you oh I'm horrible mr. riah
this used to be a recurring issue am i a
passionate bird yes but why does it
matter that we're not the same
Bonni anger might be contagious
he started it I'm a pig what Pig show
them how we doing how you doing what I
think it is scuse me
those are fragile right not yours you
won't make it I will get feel unwelcome
and you're not asking basic questions
well this just got awkward doesn't
anyone see what's going on here
the whole world is in danger anyone
knows what these pigs are up to if
Mighty Eagle get out of there don't
swallow it mmm
it's him
[Music]
horrible turn of events horrible
won't mr. riah this need to be a
recurring issue am i a passionate bird